Non. Dégage. »
[Rires]
C'est un peu une caricature de ce que je fais.
Nous refusons effectivement beaucoup, beaucoup de dessins,
tellement, qu'il y a plein de livres appelés « Le Recueil des Refusés».
« Le Recueil des Refusés » n'est pas exactement l'humour du New Yorker
Vous remarquez sans doute le clochard sur le trottoir, là,
en train de se saouler, et sa marionnette de ventriloque est en train de vomir.
Vous voyez, ça ne va probablement pas être l'humour du New Yorker.
Ça a été fait par Matt Diffee, l'un de nos dessinateurs.
Je vais vous montrer quelques exemples de ce recueil d'humour refusé.
«J'envisage de prendre un enfant."
(Rires)
Ça c'est intéressant. Le rire coupable.
Quand vous riez contre votre gré.
[Rires]
« Tête de con. Aidez-moi s'il vous plaît. »
{Rires]
En fait, dans le contexte de ce livre,
qui dit : « Dessins que vous n'avez jamais vus et que vous ne verrez jamais
dans le New Yorker »
cet humour est parfait.
Je vais vous expliquer pourquoi.
Il y a une théorie qui dit que l'humour est une transgression bénigne.
En d'autres termes, pour que quelque chose soit drôle, nous devons penser
que c'est à la fois déplacé et acceptable.
Si on pense que c'est complètement déplacé, on dit : « Ce n'est pas drôle. »
Et si ça ne nous dérange pas du tout, où est la blague ?
Et donc, cette transgression bénigne, elle se produit avec « Non, jeudi c'est impossible
Que diriez-vous de jamais ? Est-ce que jamais vous irait ? »
C'est impoli. Le monde ne devrait vraiment pas être comme ça.
Dans ce contexte, on pense que c'est acceptable.
Donc dans ce contexte, « Tête de con. Aidez-moi s'il vous plaît »
est une transgression bénigne.
Dans le contexte du magazine The New Yorker...
« L'armée des lymphocytes T : la réponse immunitaire du corps
peut-elle aider à traiter le cancer ? » Oh mon Dieu.
Vous êtes en train de lire cet article sérieux,
cette dissection intelligente du système immunitaire,
vous regardez ça sur l'autre page, et ça dit :
« Tête de con. Aidez-moi s'il vous plaît. »
Mon Dieu !
Ici, la transgression est maligne. Ça ne fonctionne pas.
Il n'y a rien qui soit drôle en lui-même ni pour lui-même.
Tout est en lien avec le contexte et avec nos attentes.
Voilà une façon de voir les choses :
C'est une sorte de théorie méta-motivationnelle sur notre apparence,
une théorie sur la motivation, et notre humeur,
et comment notre humeur va déterminer les choses que nous aimons
ou n'aimons pas.
Quand on est d'humeur enjouée, on veut de l'excitation.
On veut une forte excitation. Là, on se sent excité.
Si on est d'humeur résolue, ça nous rend anxieux.
« Le Recueil des Refusés» se situe exactement dans ce champ là.
On veut être stimulé. On veut être excité.
On veut être transgressé.
C'est comme ça, comme un parc d'attraction.
Voix : « C'est parti ! » [Cris]
Il rit. Il est à la fois en danger et en sécurité,
et incroyablement excité. Il n'y a pas de blague. Il n'en a pas besoin.
Si vous excitez suffisamment les gens, si vous les stimulez assez,
un tout petit rien les fera rire.
Voici un autre dessin du « Recueil des Refusés» : « Trop serrée ? »
C'est un dessin sur le terrorisme.
Le New Yorker occupe un espace très différent.
C'est un espace qui est enjoué à sa façon, mais aussi résolu,
et dans cet espace, les dessins sont différents.
Je vais vous montrer des dessins faits par le New Yorker
juste après le 11 Septembre, une période très, très sensible pour l'emploi de l'humour.
Comment le New Yorker s'est-t-il attaqué au sujet ?
Ça n'allait pas être avec un type portant une bombe et disant : « Trop serrée ? »
Ou il y avait un autre dessin que je ne vous ai pas montré
parce que j'ai pensé que des gens seraient peut-être choqués.
Le dessin du grand Sam Gross, il l'a fait
après la controverse sur Mahomet, on y voit Mahomet au Paradis,
le terroriste kamikaze est en petits morceaux,
et il dit au kamikaze :
« Tu auras les vierges quand on retrouvera ton pénis. »
[Rires]
Mieux vaut ne pas l'illustrer.
La première semaine, nous n'avons publié aucun dessin humoristique.
C'était un trou noir pour l'humour, et à juste titre.
Ce n'est pas approprié à tout moment.
Mais la semaine suivante, le premier dessin était celui-ci :
« Je pensais que je ne rirais plus jamais, et puis j'ai vu ta veste. »
En fait, ça disait que puisqu'on était encore en vie,
on allait rire. On allait respirer.
On allait exister. En voici un autre :
« Je me dis que si je ne prends pas un troisième martini, les terroristes auront gagné. »
Ces dessins ne parlent pas d'eux, ils parlent de nous.
L'humour nous fait réfléchir sur nous.
La chose la plus facile à faire avec l'humour, et c'est tout à fait légitime,
c'est quand un ami se moque d'un ennemi.
Ça s'appelle de l'humour de disposition.
C'est 95 pour cent de l'humour. Ce n'est pas notre humour.
Voici un autre dessin :
« Ça ne me dérangerait pas de vivre dans un Etat islamique fondamentaliste. »
[Rires]
L'humour a besoin d'une cible.
Mais ce qui est intéressant dans le New Yorker, c'est que la cible, c'est nous.
La cible, c'est le lectorat, et les gens qui le font.
L'humour est autoréflexif
et nous fait réfléchir sur nos préjugés.
Regardez ce dessin humoristique de Roz Chast, cet homme en train de lire une nécrologie :
« Deux ans de moins que toi, 12 ans de plus que toi,
trois ans plus jeune, pile ton âge,
exactement ton âge. »
C'est un dessin extrêmement profond.
Et donc le New Yorker essaie aussi, d'une certaine manière,
de publier des dessins qui ne soient pas seulement drôles,
qui nous disent quelque chose sur nous-mêmes.
En voici un autre : « Je suis devenue végétarienne pour des raisons de santé,
puis c'est devenu un choix moral, et maintenant, c'est juste pour embêter les gens. »
[Rires]
« Excusez-moi, je crois qu'il y a un problème avec ce plat.
Un problème infime que personne d'autre que moi ne pourra jamais définir exactement. »
Il est focalisé sur nos obsessions, notre narcissisme,
nos défauts et nos faiblesses,
pas ceux de quelqu'un d'autre.
Le New Yorker exige de votre part un travail cognitif,
il exige ce qu'Arthur Koestler,
qui a écrit « L'Acte de Création » sur la relation
entre l'humour, l'art et la science,
appelle la bissociation.
Il faut rassembler des idées issues de cadres de référence différents,
et il faut le faire vite pour comprendre le dessin humoristique.
Si les différents cadres de référence ne sont pas associés
en moins de 0,5 secondes, ce n'est pas drôle,
mais je pense que ça va marcher pour vous ici :
Différents cadres de référence.
« Tu as couché avec elle, avoue ? »
[Rires]
« Lassie ! Va chercher de l'aide ! »
Ça s'appelle le couteau français.
[Rires]
Et voici Einstein au lit : « Pour toi, c'était rapide. »
Il y a des dessins humoristiques qui sont déconcertants.
Ce dessin, par exemple, déconcerterait beaucoup de gens.
Combien de gens savent ce que signifie ce dessin ?
Le chien fait signe qu'il veut aller se promener.
C'est signe que le receveur doit aller faire un tour.
C'est pour ça que chaque année, dans notre hors-série dessins, nous avons une rubrique appelée :
« Je ne comprends pas : le test de Q.I. humoristique du New Yorker »
[Rires]
L'autre chose avec laquelle le New Yorker joue,
c'est l'incongruité, et l'incongruité, je vous l'ai montré,
est en quelque sorte la base de l'humour.
Quelque chose de complètement normal ou logique ne sera pas drôle.
Mais la façon dont fonctionne l'incongruité, c'est de l'humour d'observation,
c'est l'humour dans le domaine de la réalité.
« Mon chef est toujours en train de me dire ce que je dois faire. »
Okay ?
Ça pourrait arriver, c'est de l'humour dans le domaine de la réalité.
Ici, le cowboy à la vache : « Très impressionnant. J'aimerais en avoir 5000 autres comme vous. »
On comprends ça. C'est absurde. Mais on fait le rapprochement.
Ici, dans le champ de l'absurde :
« Bon sang, Hopkins, tu n'as pas eu la note d'hier ? »
C'est un peu déconcertant, non ? On ne voit pas très bien le rapport.
En général, les personnes qui apprécient le plus l'absurde
sont celles qui apprécient le plus l'art abstrait, ils sont généralement plus libéraux, moins conservateurs,
ce genre de choses.
Mais pour nous, et pour moi, dans notre travail de conception de l'humour,
ça n'a aucun sens de comparer les uns avec les autres.
C'est une sorte de smorgasbord où tout est intéressant.
Je veux résumer tout ça avec la légende d'un dessin humoristique,
je crois vraiment que ça résume tout, concernant les dessins du New Yorker :
Sur le panneau : « Arrêtez-vous et réfléchissez. » Légende : « Ça fait s'arrêter et réfléchir, non ? »
[Rires]
Et maintenant, quand vous regarderez les dessins du New Yorker,
j'aimerais que vous vous arrêtiez pour y réfléchir un peu plus.
Merci.
[Applaudissements]